today I'm pleased to introduce Carter
Hoffmann who will be presenting his
thesis proposal defense Carter is a
master student in the bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine major and
demise he received his bachelor's in
zoology from the University of
Washington where he became fascinated
with genetics and developmental biology
since then he has worked as a molecular
biologist for both academic and biotech
industry labs in the fields of
infectious disease cancer and ecology he
has worked with a variety of different
organisms including viruses bacteria
insects small rodents and humans through
his research experience he began
spending more and more time with
computational applications to solve the
research questions he was working on and
this naturally led to an interest in
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine his current area of research
is focused on strategies to identify the
human bladder microbiota
okay
okay I'm not going to kill myself I
could go right to my specific aims and
methods and you'd be fine with that but
there is a lot of background that was
involved with getting to those specific
games and it's best if I explain it all
to you so I'll be doing a brief
introduction of the microbiome and
enjoyed this some the sequencing
strategies for the study of the
microbiome and then explain some
characteristics that make for good
marker genes I don't think it'd be a
surprise to anybody to realize that
there are microbes that live in and on
our bodies all over from the backs of
our ears to the between our toes
the human microbiome project was the
first one of the first large-scale
studies to survey the bacteria from all
these body sites some of the body sites
as a start to find out what the role of
this microbiota could do to the health
of humans from this they discovered that
there's a wide variety of bacteria all
over different body sites have different
populations of makeup and that was more
of a surprise anything else other body
sites that could have been done we're
left for light at work but one exception
was the huge bladder which has been
always considered to be a sterile
environment and I remember when I was
volunteering the microbiology lab in
high school
whether text told me just flat out if
you grow anything from a urine sample it
means you're sick because that urine has
been filtered probably a blood stream by
your kidneys so anything comes into the
bladder is going to be some kind of
serious condition that you need to look
at so and with that kind of
foreshadowing the bladder is not sterile
outside of an acute infection there's a
standard population of bacteria that
just loves living in your water
some people are don't have a microbiota
in there
but majority in this study which why did
women they study did this is the work of
Alan wolf
and then the Brubaker they found the
evidence of uncultivated bacteria and
then later they actually did cultivate
bacteria this need leads naturally to
the question about what this microbiota
might be doing to the human host from
the human microbiome project they
discovered they've been working on other
body sites and discovered some uses that
the microbiota like Obama can do for the
health and for his use of chemicals some
guesses extrapolate from those studies
would be as far as like good things they
could do for a human host is to be a
physical barrier to pathogens they
compete out-compete pathogens they can
promote popular solar development for
the entire urinary tract that's a big
surprise they could degrade harmful
compounds that are introduced into the
bladder these are the good things that
might be happening of more pressing
interests are when bad things happen and
for this example the urinary
incontinence is affliction that is
complicated and I was still an active
area of research
recent key findings have been that an
altered DNA microbiome with urinary
incontinence was discovered and compared
to asymptomatic women greater symptoms
severity was discovered with lower
diversity in the microbiome and then a
relationship was observed between the
response to treatment and so with that
common a common method to get to these
conclusions would be to sample bacterial
populations from as many different
conditions as possible and then make
correlations between populations that
you've discovered or populations you've
identified and the state of the health
of the host they're key to this is
accurately identifying the bacteria in a
sample that you've obtained and for this
the sequence of the 16s are taking
ribosomal RNA genes commonly used but
it's not always the best
so with that
identifying bacteria is difficult
they're hard to see and they're hard to
characterize there's been a long history
of frustration to exactly agree on what
kind of criteria Diaz identified to
demarcate one species from another with
the advent of sequencing technologies
became easier it's still not foolproof
but with the entire genetic information
from a bacteria you can go a long way
and this is practically the gold
standard is that you take all the
genetic information from bacteria
sequence it and then compare it to known
bacteria and see where it would lie on
that on that test on a tree of life the
benefits of the whole genome sequencing
is that obviously you get every all the
information you could possibly get and
then it also allows you to predict the
functional profile of what those
capabilities of that bacteria based on
based on the sequence there are two ways
you can get the DNA to actually do the
sequencing and first one one of the ones
is the most reliable one is to actually
grow it yourself clonal populations give
you a large number of exactly the same
genetic material and sequencing that for
doing a whole genome sequencing on that
gives you a higher confidence for the
classification of bacteria and there's
no amplification bias cons for this is
that the assembly and annotation of
these genomes are difficult and
computationally intensive optimizing the
culture conditions can be very difficult
and this was realized early early by
1932 they were already publishing about
how hard it was to grow bacteria of a
specific interest a lot of work has been
done since then but if you can get
around it is desirable and lastly
sequencing an entire genome is expensive
the next strategy you get for getting
the DNA is it just extract all the DNA
from the sample and sequence everything
for human microbiome samples this
naturally includes all the host DNA or
if you're sampling dirt you get all the
DNA from other organisms that are not
coming back to your faintest interest
good news is that you do capture a
representative of the environment both
the known and the unknown bacteria the
cons obviously it obviously but the
biggest con is that there's a lot of
wasted effort due to the human
contamination from human sample like
urine and requires a high depth of
coverage due to the fact that most of
our mass is going to be your host
filtering that out leaves you with
sampling biases or losing all the DNA
samples that you could get from the
bacteria that you want and again finally
sequencing the entire genome is still
expensive and last technique I'm going
to explain here it's polymerase chain
reaction it's been around for a long
time it's robust and fairly
straightforward benefit of this is that
there's no assembly or reference mapping
required if you do the right technique
if you're just looking at the specific
amplicon that you're sequencing you're
you're not required to use a a reference
genome to map it against again choosing
light target means you can circumvent
the entire host contamination problem
there's a low coverage requirement it's
relatively inexpensive you still have to
pay for the sequencing time that you can
fit a lot more samples onto your run
than trying to get one whole genome the
cons is that it's reduced resolution for
identification necessarily a smaller
piece of DNA wants fewer information
less information than what the entire
genome does not provide any kind of
functional genetic profile and the
polymerase itself introduces errors that
need to be accounted for so with that do
you need the entire genome to make an
identification of bacteria the answer's
no you use smaller parts of informative
DNA that are not being targeted and
genes are a good start
can you use any gene in the answer again
is no bacteria have a alarming ability
to share genetic material that works
there sharing tools between themselves
they can do this in three ways they can
do the transformation which is literally
absorbing DNA loose in the environment
into their body into their cellular
structure and and that works they do
have particular extra chromosomal
genetic entity called a plasmid which
directs dedicated structures to pass do
that with Charlton so this process
actually can be passed between the donor
and recipient and then finally bacteria
get sick to phages will inject DNA into
the recipient bacteria and sometimes
it'll actually confer benefits to the
bacteria this is all considered lateral
gene transfer in the literature you
might come across the horizontal or
horizontal gene transfer and like I just
demonstrated I always trip that up so
I'm going to say lateral gene transfer
from now on the con but the downside of
this is that choosing a gene that gets
passed around through lateral gene
transfer means that identifying two
bacteria could be confused because
they're sharing the same
bypassing for themself that shows no
real taxonomic resolution the sequences
can be still very similar and that's not
a good way to choose a marker gene to
identify bacteria however some genes are
less likely to function in the recipient
bacteria and those are the ones you want
to use as market gates early on it was
identified that genes related to
transcription and translation are less
likely to work from the
transfer-resistant not that resistant is
unlikely on resistant to disease but the
physical act of transferring this DNA
into a recipient bacteria and having it
function and that formed body it's less
likely to happen so in this picture this
is vo this is a DNA strand right here
and on it are RNA polymerases that are
transcribing messenger RNA and on this
are these huge beads here are the
ribosomes they just stack up as soon as
there's enough room from the sort
translating it to protein in the 70s
Carl was identified that ribosomes are
shared in all forms of life and this
would be a good way to determine
relations of the Tree of Life using that
specific characteristics first he did
digested fragments of ibis ohms later
once sequencing technology got good
enough they went straight to note the
gene sequence
so this is a so this is it here this is
a picture of the ribosome it's got two
subunits it's large subunit small
subunit it's got several different it's
made up of several different several
different materials here you've got
protein which assists the folding of the
ribosomal RNA and then inside there
you've got some transfer RNA and I'll
come back to that part later for this
this part this ribosomal RNA here is
used was used by it by Pavlos and
commonly still today as a reliable
method for the most part to identify
bacteria this is a secondary structure
on the ribosomal RNA of E coli and I'm
going to spill the beans here this red
part here this is the v4 region this is
a smaller part of the entire sequence
and this can be used reliably to
identify bacteria and this is commonly
used nowadays for the bladder microbiome
so in summary a good carrying at market
gene is one that's likely to resist
lateral gene transfer and therefore the
differences between sequences are due to
mutation rate there are genes present in
all bacteria and at least the
environment of interest there are
studies well they will they'll find
homologs
in the environment of bacteria they
expect to find a little sample the
bacteria of that area and compare the
genomes and find a genes that are good
for that specific environment and then
the next one there's a single copy some
genes are present in multiple copies in
bacteria the 16s gene is one example and
then finally the best a good quality is
that these these gene these proteins are
part of larger complexes
for now I'm not discovering marker genes
on my own there's been work and the
success of these two studies has left us
with 40 protein encoding marker genes
that could be used to identify bacteria
for this paper here from Francisco Ching
Carelli she used the computational
method of comparing thousands of known
genomes of bacteria and picking out the
genes are present in all of them and
then later random Sorek did a laboratory
validation of these marker genes and
from his laboratory work he showed that
these genes are resistant to being
loitering transfer between bacteria so
I'll be using this list so what are some
examples of these for the most part the
40 marker genes are involved with the
ribosome and majority are these proteins
that guide the correct folding of the
ribosomal RNA there's over 20 here these
are all good these are all good
candidates to used to identify bacteria
with the next class are the specific
enzymes that attach the amino acid
residue to the transfer RNA but called
trna synthetases there's two classes one
class is a small enzyme all in one piece
that will do the attach together acid
residue those are not good for marker
genes and I've already read those out
from the list but these are known the
next class is what the important one is
this is the synthetase here it's got two
subunits this or this pink part here is
the transfer RNA and because these are
multi subunit complexes this is this is
a better candidate of this class of
Moloch
the next two that are used are the alpha
and beta subunit of the RNA polymerase
the blue parts here are the alpha beta
subunit their clamps that hold onto the
DNA strand as its transcribing messenger
RNA and finally there's like a small
collection of associated enzymes that
will charge the RNA sorry charge the
ribosome with energy or in this case
we'll move unfolded protein across the
membrane into the periplasmic space here
so for this specific marker gene it'd be
the SEC wide right here in this green
part okay do you need the entire gene no
not always
you can pick smaller parts of the gene
there are more informative parts of just
that gene that can be used and for that
for an example that I've got again the
secondary structure of the 16s RNA gene
between bacteria the bacterial domain
and the archaea domain and these orange
parts are the variable regions or the
parts that are variable v4 region does
cover a large a larger part of this but
these are these are the important ones
here so if you would take this these RNA
sequences of actually the gene sequences
this is this is the transcribed RNA but
the gene sequences are reflective of
this difference here I can compare this
part with this part and I could tell
from at least I'd say all these that
this is bacterial and this is an
entirely different domain of life so
with that ago my specific aims now so my
first aim is to find single variable
regions from marker genes and compared
them to how successful they identify
bacteria from the human bladder to the
v4 region of the 16s RNA gene this will
be a one-to-one comparison from all 40
genes well sorry from the culled down
list of 40 genes I'm removing the
synthetase molecules that are
prone to a lateral gene transfer but of
those 30-some marker genes they will all
have variable regions in them and I
could take each one of those and compare
it to the v4 region and 16s gene by
itself second aim is to compare sets or
combinations of variable regions to the
v4 region by itself and then lastly be
nice to see if this actually works in
the real world so I'm gonna go ahead and
do it
after design after just some finding out
which marker regions are going to be
best compared to the v4 region I'll
design primers for them and then
amplified DNA extracted from urine
samples from the Lisa Tarsus level the
sequences are important I can't just do
this out of thin air and I don't want to
use genomes that are related to other
parts of the world I want to use
bacteria found in dirt even though they
are universal market genes lucky for me
crystal Thomas white and Ellen wolf have
actually cultured bacteria out of out of
human urine from human bladders and
isolated them and then sequence them the
entire genome this is fantastic
I'll be I'll be using these gene
sequences to to find my variable regions
based on these bacteria that are
specific to the human bladder so what
they found was 149 I slit is covered 78
different species and they are from
represent of just three phyla of many in
the patchy old domain so how to do this
I'll be constructing multi-species
alignments and of those I'll be looking
for parts that are not concerned tends
to be developer regions and then during
my first and second specific game
comparing these regions to the v4 region
the 16s gene and then last step is to
validate these identified member regions
on urine samples which is to design the
partners extract DNA from urine samples
sequencing amplicons and then assign
taxonomy the method is based on multi
species or multi sequence alignment this
is a difficult problem aligning two
genes to install for two sequences to
themselves is solved
it's a little bit of work but it's not
as difficult as trying to align many
many many different different sequences
together and nowadays work as being work
typically involves aligning like tens of
thousands of sequences with each other
there are there are specific algorithms
that do this kind of work and they're a
big advancement I'm not gonna go that
detailed there is a alignment program an
algorithm that was made for small groups
of multi sequences like a hundred
sequences or less I don't have that many
I have about 78 sequences Tucumcari so
this is a good a good fit the method
trying to align all these sequences to
themselves all at once is extremely
difficult so to get around this by doing
a heuristic of doing pairwise alignments
all possible pairwise alignments and
then building a guide tree and then
those sequences that are the most common
the most identical to each other are
aligned first and then the increasingly
less identical sequences are added to it
until it's progressively
progressively I did until the full
alignment is complete for this for this
algorithm it's called tea coffee and it
was designed by Notre Dame minute and
colleagues in their paper they use the
example of these four sequences here I'm
sure you've read it by now so paralyzed
alignment on professor alignment without
in the in the first attempts suffered
from aligning sequences that had
fantastic pairwise scores but were not
necessarily the best for the full
multi-species alignment so errors that
were introduced early in it in the
alignment were compounded until finally
the final sequence multiple sequence
alignment was not the best case those
steps are to first do a global
alignments of each possible pairwise
alignment and in this example there's
the for the foreign sequences line in
the six different ways to each other and
then they're scored for percent identity
and in this scoring method mismatches
count against you but these dashes here
these are called insertions or
innovations or are just proof the other
is called indels these don't count so
even though this is obviously not you
know a hundred percent identical to each
other there are no mismatches so that
way that score is a hundred percent and
these are these are less so after that a
guide rate is a guide tree is created
and I just work their way down they
start with these two sequences and then
add sequence II and then add sequence D
at the end of it the problem is that you
can see here just visually you can just
push this over to here there's a strong
urge for me to just push us over to this
side and be a be a better alignment this
is the this is the downside of
progressive or alignment without any
kind of consideration about the big
picture tea/coffee adds a consistency
method to this so again it starts off by
making all pairwise
alignments and then it goes through
every possible every possible
combination and looks about it looks at
how consistently each of these letters
are aligned with the other corresponding
letter in this case the word the is
consistently aligned with each other for
something like fat and fast it's maybe
not quite as consistent or sometimes not
at all
sequence D has no information to give
about Garfield so that isn't including
the weight at the end of it you have a a
list of weighted values that will inform
the dynamic programming so as this
dynamic programming is going through the
final alignment these three letters will
be consistently will be will be weighted
to align against each other and over
here last these weights are smaller than
having fat align with fast and at the
end here you see that doesn't really
good job at making a better alignment so
I'll be using that the good news is that
the good the good part for me about that
is that tea/coffee outputs two files
that I can use one is the actual
alignment and the second is the guide
tree so for example there is a multi
sequence multi-species alignment each
sequence from the Thomas white data set
is aligned along the rows here this is
the 16s RNA gene sequence its full
length goes from zero to a little over
1,500 base pairs if you look at it by
eye you can see that sorry so the score
of the rep of the position here whatwhat
are lined up at this position the
residues line of this position here are
almost identical and here's an identical
stack of residues and here's an
identical stack and when you get these
blank spaces here these deep valleys
that means that they're not they're not
matching
there's big deletions or insertions
there you just look at it by eye which I
did at first you can kind of see that
here's a group here here's repair here's
from here these are putting obvious
variable regions these were not I
wouldn't pick those out on my own so
doing it by eye is not a good idea these
variable regions have been mapped out on
the E coli genome and I'm using those
those map positions here on this diagram
so this is variable region one this
difference here is due to the fact that
the bacteria that I'm aligning are
specific to the bladder whereas
otherwise if I'd used like all the
genome sequences on NCBI would be a
different different alignments core
there are nine regions mapped out and
they match pretty well and just as a
note this is a tea coffee multi sequence
alignment I did do it with coastal Omega
which is the progressive liner that can
do tens of thousands of sequences again
sorry guys that does lose some accuracy
and I think it was this I think it was
the v6 region here
there's a giant dip right there with the
tea coffee that's not that's not
included there so that's good news
so to identify these rebel regions
without using behinds take solutely
think so let the computer do that work
so that is a sliding window analysis so
this is this is the the output file from
tea coffee of the multi sequence
alignment and this is not I'm going to
take a window of two hundred base pairs
this is not two innovators here but it
wouldn't fit on the screen so this is
the window
250 250 base pairs is saying I deal with
length for the my secret sequencer black
one and I'm going to use the score of
these positions to sum up a total score
for this window and in this position
here I've got a high score and as this
window moves along stepwise and I add up
those scores they're going to get worse
and worse and worse and worse until I
bought them out here and then as I move
along further to a part that's conserved
that score is gonna get better and
better and better and better until
finally I'll get this this is the ideal
situation here this is the variable
region element identify and the best
cases that's flanked by two completely
conserved 100% identical regions that's
the best case for designing primers I
don't expect that to happen all the time
so the next step is to do the comparison
of the variable regions to do that I'm
going to use the guide tree that's
generated by tea coffee so this is the
full guide tree here this is the this is
the map that tea coffee uses to do in
small ties to build the multi sequence
alignment and on there this is being
generated by a pairwise pairwise
similarity it's got like the most
unfortunate acronym ever I think it's an
unweighted pair group method with
arithmetic mean I can't pronounce the
open it's one of them but what it means
is that it uses a distance metric to to
cluster sequences together
and so finding you get this guide tree
and the branch lengths here indicate how
how far apart how different those
sequences are so here a branch length of
0 means those two sequences are
identical and here are three identicals
sequences here they happen to be strange
of the same species so that's to be
expected this is preliminary data and I
included strains inside this inside this
first multi species alignment for the
final project I'll have to curate that
to make sure there are no strange
because I don't I'm not looking to get
strain level resolution
that's and then here's another branch of
strains of the same species these are
these are to be expected and ignored so
this is what I'm looking for these two
species have identical v3 sequences this
is I forgot to mention sorry this is a
this is a multi species alignment of
just the d3 region and for this the v3
region cannot tell these two species
apart from each other this is bad but I
expect that one region
I don't expect one region to be able to
identify all the species of bacteria in
a sample which is why I'm also going to
be doing
comparing multiple variable regions with
each other so of that I can I can just
count these up and then from that I can
tell how many species each of these
variable regions correctly identified so
there's the gold standard or the
standard so far is the variable the v4
available region identified 69 of 84
species correctly that's 82% and then
compared to these three other variable
regions - b3 b6 + b8 now managed us to
identify more species correctly and they
have a higher percentage here you'll
notice these are tied b8 and v3 they're
not but they're they identified more
species than the v4 correctly but not
the same species and that's in this
slide here so this is the final this
will be the final step in this method
which is to find the minimal set of
variable regions that can cover the
entire species population in that sample
and for the the 16s gene for each of
these 3 of these 4 available regions
Staphylococcus is difficult it
consistently confuses these two species
with each other
and for the p4 it also adds an extra one
down here billion Ella is another
difficult one for them for all four of
them but when the filos is really
difficult to determine and then these
others are
genus level identification so genus
levels not bad I'd like to get species
that's that's the goal but Jesus isn't
okay for now and then again up here are
the two unrelated species that are
confused with each other which I might
have to I'm gonna have to weed out so it
might be that from this I would say if I
had to pick two of these I might pick
like the v8 region and the v3 region and
then look for other marker genes to fill
out the rest of the the rest of the
populations then finally to do the
validation be designing and testing the
primers on extracted DNA sequencing
amplicons and assigning taxonomy so i
said the best case these rubble regions
will be flanked by completely conserved
regions in the case that they're flanked
by regions that are not completely
conserved I'll be using degenerate
primers and I'll use code hop for that
so there's this diagram here that means
that for all those all those read all
those all those segments that are
different from each other I have to
design one primer to be able to amplify
that that's that section so of this I'll
need roughly for this example it looks
like there's sixteen different primers
that are necessary so if you know any CA
and so on until you get all sixteen
different primers to use in that set
this is the degenerate part but code hop
is a established way of doing this
then finally sort of signed taxonomy
I'll be using ID taxa which I can train
on the Thomas white data set and it
assigns the statistical confidence level
to the taxon design to it this is how
long I think it'll take August with luck
I'll be done and then that covers
everything like that my mentor Lisa and
my thesis Advisory Committee which is
Mark and Michael and Holly and then
everyone else at device Christina Zhang
for questions I had about sequencing the
Karstens lab in all listen to my
presentation more time to make air unit
and then the aspirant lab for I'll be
eventually using their materials in
their space thank you for sharing that I
was really glad you showed us some
preliminary data because the question I
thought about at the beginning when you
started was would you be able to do
specific aim three if nothing performed
so well in specific aims you know wanted
to as to be identified as being better
candidates so I'm a little reassured
because you've shown some evidence that
you think they will be better candidates
but I'd love for you to talk a little
bit more about how much better do they
have to be to kind of meet your
definition of being better candidates
and you know to make it worth doing this
Pacific Game three differently
yeah okay look no I'm trying to then
yeah I I think once I have this in front
of me I'll be able to see seated clear
plant pattern there is there is a little
bit of nervousness because these
sequences are only 300 base pairs
forward
for this work what they did was they
used the they did the full genome
sequence and then they see it maybe they
used the 40 marker genes they just
pulled up the 40 mark of genes sequences
and concatenate all together so they've
got 40 times however long those genes
are then they use that to match against
a database that's not an entire genome
but it is still a lot of information and
I'll be using even less at that
hopefully more just as informative
though so I think it would be if there
reliably distinguishing between a set of
species and then even if they are not
reliably identifying the other 140
isolates I can still pick up some other
variable region from a different marker
gene hopefully it's going to be a small
set there could be I've never have about
how many rebel regions are going to be
in these functional marker genes the
ones that encode proteins it could be I
don't think it'll be nine for one but
maybe five so five times 42 it still a
lot so I'm hoping in those numbers that
I'll be able to find something something
that will cover the entire set reliably
but yeah as far as I've exact threshold
I haven't
I thanks for an interesting talk I do
have a couple of questions about the
details of the methodology which weren't
clear to me it sounds like I'm probably
wrong but you're when you're looking at
whether you can distinguish one back
here from another you're looking at like
any difference in the base pair window
oh is that the case or is there some
threshold of a difference or some
sliding scale of differences using and
the reason I'm asking is because you
know it isn't my specialty but it would
seem that when you when you translate
this into its eventual you know clinical
goal which is some you know fast
clinical tops for doing this that more
distinction would be easier to measure
and easier to build a micro or a chip or
whatever it is so just you know what are
your thoughts about you know how much
difference that you really need or how
you will you will measure the difference
is really necessary right so so for
example so of this for this I pick a
threshold of 0.025 and that corresponds
to roughly at 5% difference of two new
sequences this is not assigned taxonomy
though this is this is a threshold I
picked just to find it just to use as a
degree of similarity to those sequences
to each other it was a short three base
pair sequences to each other I'm
depending on ID taxa for the final like
confidence level about how what
threshold I should be using so for this
for this when I was just eyeballing it
there seemed to be there seemed to be a
clunk where you had like zero and then a
few more values above that and then a
large gap of empty space and then
everything else was larger values of
course but the larger distances so of
that I'm gonna be looking at exactly how
those data clumps or clusters be looking
for like
having that then and tell me the
threshold I can use to so reliably
separate these things out
yeah I wonder if there's like a multi
objective optimization and this is you
want to you want to both separate
everything as well as ready to fight
though by them you want to cover
everything so yeah right but you also
want it separated by as much as possible
yeah and that's what the variable
regions would be for those are the parts
of the gene that are most different from
from each other I don't expect it to be
as stringent as a single base pair
difference that's that's not I can't
expect that but then again I can't just
say you know anything over 10 base pairs
is going to be something that is just a
lot of considering you have an idea just
looking at again I'm practical and
aspects what level of difference is you
know the people would be confident they
could does create probes and stuff that
would be reliable and you know I mean
and use that sort of as a as a minimum
threshold what you know what would be
practical in the long run kind of kind
of thing
sorry just well like you know we're
trying to separate this so when we with
the eventual technology that's going to
use this how much difference do you need
for that technology in the end to be
reliable whether it's right DNA probes
on the DNA might throw
oh no I mean one base pair doesn't seem
realistic right yeah real estate no
partial binding and all that kind of
stuff but you know a thousand seems way
more than you would need so you know
what is the you know so for this it's
just I'm looking for the the amount of
differences in those variable regions I
don't know if you could I wasn't
considering like a step back from that
and said like making probes of these to
these specific regions any kind of DNA
probe that'd be making would be the
primers themselves which are actually
gonna be located outside those places
but yeah I would have to expect you to
look at and what I pull out of this data
to see if there's a there's a a concrete
way of determining a threshold for that
so one other little question it is not
related to the first question is hi how
do you know what the answers are to the
gold standard do you have these urine
samples how do you know what's the right
answer
I don't it's that's the I have some
expectations I expect that this is this
is slightly akin to like a training set
and a test set the training set would be
would be these sequences because there
they were extracted from bacteria in the
bladder so my expectation is that having
amplicons
specific from this or built from this
data set is going to be able to also I
gotta find bacteria in an unknown data
set of urine samples I would not expect
to find things like deep-sea vents back
to Ariane sequences in there
but as that's what the that's what the
way of doing the taxon this assignment
would be for using I'd attach it to
train this data set the identification
of those
would give me a confidence about if I'm
what I'm looking at an unknown bacteria
just how confident can I be saying yes
these bacteria in it as far as the
unknown bacteria that I don't know are
in that population
I really have no way I'm saying if
they're not right there are always at
least the possibility that in the end of
bacteria their sequences look like some
of the known bacteria so you get you
know kind of a false positive I wonder
if there's any way to you know improve
that by you know also looking for
similar things that you don't expect to
be there and somehow showing that
they're not there you know it's always
difficult when you don't actually know
what the right answers yeah a new sample
that's I mean I guess the standard
answer would be to use some other more
laborious laboratory technique on some
subset that's what this is they actually
grew it out there and the answer that
beats you take more samples for more
waters that have and extract the DNA and
do more extra culture than that
right
[Applause]